hello
and welcome to this talk on safe fare
and ethical ai
a practical approach which i hope is
useful in your own organizations
this talk has two ambitions it aims to
present a practical framework for
organizing all the different kinds of
questions around risks and mitigations
and controls that emerge
as we try to make our systems safe fair
and ethical
it also tries to i guess stimulate um
some discussion around conceptual
clarity
which i feel is not quite there when
compared with more
established disciplines like medicine or
information security or
civil engineering a little bit about
myself before we get started
i originally trained as a physicist a
long time ago my first job was actually
at a nuclear facility
i've worked in technology for i guess 20
25 years
and a fair bit of that in central
government where i saw firsthand
the impact of data and algorithms on
citizens on communities i'm really
passionate about um
supporting and nurturing and growing and
the importance of communities
and i've in the past organized
co-organized the london python meetup
i've established the algorithmic art
group in london which is quite big now
i run the data science group in cornwall
and i run a children's code club as well
i'm the author of a few books on machine
learning um
take a look at them they're designed to
be as accessible as possible
and i also run a business digital
dynamics
which focuses on helping other
organizations
understand their risks around their use
of data
algorithms development processes
and how they've organized their
governance as they try
to make sure their products and services
are safe
fair and ethical the last few years have
seen
a real growth in the adoption of machine
learning and ai
they've also seen some real leaps
forward in
ai capability however we've also seen
a rise in the number of instances where
data
and algorithms haven't been designed and
used well
um there are lots of examples of these
and here's just a selection
um the home office was in the news for
um
an algorithm which biased against people
of a certain
origin um and it was in the news again
for
um a particularly um um unpleasant um
uh story around embarrassing against
people of a certain skin color
um we saw this summer lots of news and
discussion
in public as well around the mutant
algorithm which unfairly penalized
students
just for being from a particular region
or school
even large organizations with huge
budgets and expertise in machine
learning and ai can get it wrong
we've seen for example news stories
about amazon's recruitment system
which in effect learned to replicate
historic biases um and the scale of
social media is something we can't
ignore where even
subtle um issues with the algorithmic
recommendation
can have a huge impact on society in
terms of polarization
and potentially the spread of um
incorrect facts
so we know we need to do something about
this and
lots of questions emerge
you know there's lots of guidance around
explainability de-anonymization human in
the loop
data drift selection bias lots and lots
of things that we should be thinking
about and it can feel like
we're sort of drowning in this deluge of
questions
so what we need is a way of organizing
these questions
into a framework which makes logical
sense
so that we can be sure that we've not
left anything out
and it also allows us to compare our
work with others
we should also understand that assurance
in ai
is a relatively new field and in
comparison to more established
practices like information security or
the disciplines around medicine
pharmaceuticals and civil engineering
the assurance in ai is really very much
immature
it's at the starting blocks so there
isn't a consensus or a
tried and tested approach and with that
in mind
we're much more comfortable
understanding why sometimes there are
mixed messages around
how we should do this but the good news
is that
actually consensus is forming fairly
rapidly and i think we'll be
accelerating at this curve
within the next year or two
and as an indication of that immaturity
it's interesting that in this field of
ai
we don't have a commonly agreed scheme
or language for describing how things go
wrong
in a way that other people can
understand as well
and that exists in many other fields and
is a sign of their maturity
but the good news is is that we can
learn from those other fields
there's actually quite a lot we can take
from
the field of information security which
has been developing over the last 20 30
40 years so where we are at the moment
is many governments and national
organizations have been
in the process of consulting and
developing guidance around you know good
use of ai
and it's surprising actually the extent
to which
a lot of those overlap so if we look at
you know
guidance put out by the us government
department of defense
over there the uk's own touring
institute
nhs ada lovelace institute
if we look at you know europe the eu
itself has put out
guidance around the use of ai
and actually you know i'd say 70 80
percent of it
is in overlap which is good news because
it means there isn't a deep schism or
the deep
division in how we want to approach
what eventually becomes the regulation
and
many of us do think that a lot of this
consultation a lot of this kind of
guidance will become regulation
because it is clear that the current
data protection laws
aren't sufficient to protect citizens
with respect to the use of algorithms so
in short
our current legislation focuses on data
protection
not on algorithmic safety
so let's get started in this discussion
of conceptual clarity
what do we mean by it it means that we
really need to be
clear crystal clear on what our
objective is what are we trying to
preserve
with all the work we do what is it that
we're trying to protect or maximize
and in order to make that task easier it
helps to be able to decompose that
objective
into smaller elements
um dimensions pillars facets so that we
can work on them in turn
and think about them more in a more
focused way
and it's important that those dimensions
those smaller elements are actually
orthogonal
and and together they complete
our objective this might sound abstract
and it might sound
perhaps obvious but actually you know
lots of the guidance around ai assurance
doesn't have that clarity um it you know
many of the things that they talk about
in terms of what we should aim to do or
preserve are overlapping or are actually
subsets of each other
or the picture isn't complete there is
actually a major technology vendor
which doesn't include transparency in
any of its um
discussion around in a high principles
which is
unfortunate so let's illustrate this
idea of conceptual clarity
and look at a field where i think it
does exist
if you're familiar with it you'll know
that information security is often
decomposed
into three pillars confidentiality
integrity and availability
and they are orthogonal to each other
they are different
and together they more or less complete
the questions around information
security and it allows us to think about
the controls and measures we put in
place
in terms of whether they actually
achieve information security by covering
all three pillars
or whether we perhaps duplicate our
efforts or have a gap so it's a very
helpful thing to be able to do
and we should be able to do that with
with um ai assurance
the other really important thing we can
do with
this kind of clarity and it's really
important in business
is to be able to provide justifiability
traceability
from controls all the way up to
our overall objective by drawing
pictures like this by saying we've
implemented a control or a process
or a mitigation and it supports
availability
which is a part of security it also
allows us to have discussions around
proportionality
should we do it to what extent should we
do it how much money should we spend on
it
what disruption should it be allowed to
cause
and actually as part of the healthy
debate around
what is information security some people
over the years have proposed a fourth
pillar non-repudiation
and that's positive and healthy because
what it means is
we are constantly thinking about what
that decomposition should be
and whether actually we've been missing
out some
um risks um and not meeting against them
properly
so this kind of updating and challenge
is good and we need to see that
in this practice of machine learning and
ai
so let's go back to this field of
machine learning and ai
and ask ourselves what is the overall
objective what are we trying to
maximize or preserve is it privacy or
does that belong in information security
is it transparency is that the overall
um
target should it be something like
explainability
perhaps it's accuracy because a system
that's inaccurate is
is going to be unfair to people
and this debate um is vibrant at the
moment
i wouldn't say it's settled but
consensus is starting to emerge
and we should continue doing that
actually because people
are still publishing guidance where some
of these themes are actually not
orthogonal
they're subsets of each other all those
gaps as i said earlier
in some of them transparency is missing
as a result of our own work and quite a
lot of
discussion and debate and taking part in
kind of
virtual groups and workshops where we
really bash out and
you know kick these uh these ideas to
really test them
we have our own a consensus that i think
is right
um but the debate will continue and the
and the answer that we think is right is
this
we think the overall objective is
trustworthy systems and you can disagree
with that as an overall objective
but we found this to be a really helpful
um top level objective and underneath
that
we didn't want too many um you know
pillars and
and and facets and we've managed to know
then down to
three or four fairness which is a fairly
broad term which we can talk about a
little bit more in a minute
um you know the idea that these systems
treat people
equally and don't do any harm um
transparency
because if we don't understand how those
things work if we don't know what
they're doing
um how can we really trust them um
it's hard to trust something if you
can't see it and an important part of
that is
that transparency has to be
understandable what we see has to be
understandable
accountability is really important um
we've talked about that
in terms of um being able to respond
appropriately when things go wrong being
able to
be accessible to those who are perhaps
the victims of a system gone wrong
[Music]
and privacy is an interesting one and
we originally didn't want to include it
because it really is um
you know usually sits under the umbrella
of information security
however we have found that there are you
know a
significant class of algorithms and data
processing
which de-anonymizes data in a way that's
the
subjects of that data are perhaps not
aware of or didn't consent to
so that's becomes so significant that
it's
one of the four pillars
and actually a lot of the um themes and
objectives that people
will um raise and do care about
can fit under these four pillars
so equality is really important to to to
people
um some people care a lot about
technical accuracy
whether a system um can achieve
a good predictive behavior for example
that can fit under fairness because if
it's not behaving accurately
it's not behaving fair others will
worry about broad questions around
no system should harm anyone should
respect human autonomy
these can fit under the under the
umbrella of fairness
similarly um questions around um you
know
public insight into how systems work
naturally fits under transparency
but so do those concerns around whether
whether it is explainable fits under
this umbrella as well
in our experience many organizations are
actually very good on the
technology and the software development
but perhaps a little bit weaker on
accountability
and that raises questions around whether
that
accountability is accessible to the
public or to the subjects of their um
their kind of products and services
whether that accountability is
responsive
um but there's an actual cost of
doing things wrong and if there isn't if
there isn't a disincentive
that can be an issue and as we've said
this question of privacy the main issue
around that
with respect to machine learning and ai
is de-anonymization
so let's get started step one is to
build a map to scope out our systems
and we do that by drawing um boxes on a
piece of paper
mapping out um data sources
data flows the technology and the
algorithms we use
and that's you know very comfortable for
many of us but actually it's not
sufficient
we also need to include the development
process
in that because that can make a
significant difference
to how safe fair and ethical our systems
are
i will see more about that in a minute
and we can't stop there we also need to
include
people because data is often about
people
um the systems are often making
decisions or
their outputs are affecting people and
there are people
in your organization who are developing
these systems
are responsible and accountable for them
and they need to be part of this picture
that we draw out
so the next step is to establish impact
what is at stake when things go wrong
what what's the fallout
and surprisingly this is um we find
people don't do this it's it's amazing
because
without doing this you can't calibrate
your response
um you need to understand what is at
stake
in order for you to justify the work
that you do to prevent it going wrong
so you need to understand what happens
to your subjects
if the system goes wrong and there might
be several ways in which it goes wrong
you might be recommending which choose
to buy next in which case if you get
that wrong
there's no harm to somebody's health or
or life
i mean it might be inconvenient there
might be a little bit of a financial
cost to yourselves
if you're making systems that are
medical in nature so recommending
medication or diagnosing disease
the impact of getting that wrong is very
high
and therefore that has to drive
the resources and effort into making
sure
that that doesn't happen or there is a
suitable response if it does
and actually this is something that is
overlooked
even if the output of a system
is subtly wrong and is perhaps
imperceptible or immeasurable
when it comes to one subject when scaled
out to entire communities
this the impact can be significant
so it's worth bearing in mind that
actually you should
look at the aggregate impact not just
narrowly focus on the impact of one
individual
once we've understood the impacts and we
know what ballpark we're playing in
in terms of seriousness we then
establish
what kinds of risks apply
and that's where this framework really
comes into its own
we can look at the map that we built in
the scope
and we can methodically apply those four
pillars
fairness transparency accountability
privacy to each of those domains
we can apply it to data the algorithm
the
the people involved um the communities
involved
and and that's that's an exhaustive um
and thorough process
and will take some time to do properly
so we won't do that here
but we'll look at some examples just to
illustrate the idea
so for example you might say well how
does transparency apply to
the algorithms we're using do we
understand what the algorithms are doing
are they closed proprietary software
where we don't really know what they're
doing
or is the algorithm open is the software
open source
so who's accountable for this system
that we're building
not responsible in terms of development
and building and
testing but who's who's whose neck is
online
when when things don't go right you need
to understand who that person is
and that person might not know they're
accountable do they know what they're
accountable for
do they know what to do when things go
wrong
is there a playbook do they practice
um what actions to take when things go
wrong
we don't often see that
and accountability is not just about the
person inside your organization
we need to think about the subjects the
citizens or users
can they access your organization's
processes for identifying when
something's gone wrong
to be able to complain or to alert and
then for action to be taken in response
to that
that feedback is really important and
you should really be thinking about and
testing
whether a subject can actually reach
your organization reach the right person
and have the right corrective measures
take place and perhaps compensation as
well
does your algorithm de-anonymize data as
i said earlier
privacy is sometimes seen as a concern
of information security
but we have seen actually in bringing
data together and
using interesting algorithms can expose
more about the subjects of those data
than they thought that they had given
consent to
in terms of fairness you know you might
ask a technical question such as
is the data biased is the data drifting
after it's gone live so we might have
tested our system
works really nicely it's gone live but
then over time the input data
is moving so these are the kinds of
questions that we should be
answering as a as part of this process
of applying this framework
and there are many other kinds of
examples i could go into and it wouldn't
be interesting here to
list out all the different combinations
so once we've done that once we've kind
of established some of those risks
we need to think about proportionate
controls and measures that we put in
place and we're now in a position
where we can justify them we know why
we're doing them
and here's just some examples just to
kind of illustrate the idea
it might be that the output of our
system is
so um life-changing
and and potentially important
um to an end-user to a citizen
that actually it's only right that there
is a human
in that loop so it's not an automated
process
you know a person a qualified person
uses the output of our
automated system and is there as the
person
that um um brings the information on
news to to the citizen
that can be justified now what we said
earlier around
understanding impacts you know if we're
recommending um we choose to buy next
that's not justified and you don't need
to do that
whereas if you've made a diagnosis and
the results are potentially
good or bad or unclear this is justified
and there's another scenario where a
human in the loop makes sense
so for perhaps intermediate impact
situations
you might have a machine output where
it's not certain what the
correct answer is it's not certainly a
and it's not certainly b it's something
in between we're not really sure
and and it can make sense then to flag
to a human to say look
the the algorithm isn't certain about
what the right answer is we need a human
to get involved
and that's a very good example of human
in the loop
it might be that actually you justify
shutting down your entire system
if it's producing um very widely
um out of range answers
or people are starting to complain
that that can be justified and again
your justification is based on
you know understanding the impact
in fact you know we don't often see this
but more organizations should do it
monitoring the input where actually your
input is drifting
and is nothing like the data it was
trained on or expected
and you should be setting up automated
uh sense checking of your data and if
you know if it's quality is degrading or
it's
you know variance is all over the place
you might decide to alert or stop the
system
rather than proceed with you know unsafe
data garbage and garbage out
in other situations it's really
important to be able to justify
the decisions that your system made and
that
you know and what is at stake can
justify the expense and effort
of implementing a fully auditable and
repeatable archive of your development
process
again if you're recommending shoes that
perhaps isn't justifiable
whereas if you're recommending
medication or health treatments
and you know you can see yourself ending
up in in a court or
another process where you have to be
able to justify
how your algorithm was trained on what
data
what the parameters were and why you
thought it was safe
and and to be able to prove that you
haven't tampered with
that record and that can be a an
appropriate response as well
um and and something else actually again
that we don't see enough organizations
um
think about is is address the risk of
group think or narrowthink where
you know the team is very talented but
but actually doesn't really
understand the context from which the
data came
or the context of the users and this is
why it's really important to have
diverse teams and particularly
representative teams
working in your organization because
some things just aren't apparent unless
you have that life experience
so now that we've talked a little bit
about this framework let's compare it to
those emerging frameworks coming from
those national bodies
and this is a picture taken from the you
know eu guidance
and as i said earlier it's you know 78
similar to every other
official publication and we can see
a lot of the themes are the same you can
see transparency over here
we can see technical robustness and
safety which implies testing
which implies understanding how your
systems perform under different
circumstances
we've seen here a little bit about
privacy accountability
and i've highlighted here things around
items around um
human agency and oversight um
being able to kind of understand the
societal environmental impact of our
systems when looked at like this as a
sort of a star chart
they all make sense but actually through
the framework that we're proposing
you can see why they're important you
can see that human agency and oversight
is important in certain impact scenarios
where
it is justified that there is a human in
the loop
we can also understand how you know for
life-changing decisions it's important
that the subject has
recourse to your governance to be able
to
correct an error so you can see how the
framework that we're proposing has these
objectives
in a in a in a more logical context
i talked earlier about more mature
sectors and what we can learn from them
so let's pick out a few examples of
lessons we can learn so this question of
a black box emerges a lot in discussions
around ai ethics and
you know understandability or not about
how
um and perhaps in your network or other
other models work actually
many other sectors have systems which
are not 100 deterministic
um for example medicine we don't always
know
how and why they work in some people
medicine has an effect which we can't
explain
so that doesn't mean we don't use
medicine
what we do instead is we build our
confidence through testing
we test diversely we test at scale
until we've reached a point where we can
say
this medicine works in you know
99 or 99.99 of cases
and we're happy that in a small number
of people
there will be an adverse effect but
we've also understood what those adverse
effects are
so the point here is testing and
understanding how a system behaves
can in some cases be a good response
to the black box problem
if we look at engineering civil
engineering building machines
we've been doing that for hundreds and
thousands of years we've got quite good
at
understanding how to build them and test
them
and in particular understanding their
operating characteristics
when we build machines and tools we know
we
test for their for the situations in
which they work best
you know which temperature range they
work best in and then how do they start
to fail
outside that central region you know as
we increase the temperature or the
humidity
does material rapidly crumble or does it
take a while to break this this
development of operating characteristics
is something we need to do more of
in in the machine learning world and
testing and continuous testing
um we are actually quite good at in in
software engineering
but actually in the machine learning
community
we've too often built systems that we've
tested and then deployed
and not continuously tested them
so let's look at this question of ethics
which actually is quite
challenging for um for many people in in
a technical field
because it's very um in concrete it's
it's very kind of you know abstract and
philosophical and
hard to pin down um by its nature you
know
if you have discussions with
philosophers and ethicists
and sociologists sort of terminology
around
you know utilitarianism and
existentialism and deontological ethics
and so on and so on
and it can feel a little bit despairing
about you know how do we turn
that very lively and sometimes
wishy-washy discussion
into something concrete and practical
and
our conclusion really is
that yes ethics can be subjective and
yes there are many views on it
but ultimately um
it's a choice a set of choices that you
or your organization makes
and understanding those choices being
conscious of them
is important so
no organization is objective or neutral
in every organization is
made up of people with their own
experiences and biases and beliefs
and so on and that is you know seeps
into the technology that we build
if we're aware of that to some extent we
can try and mitigate it
but a better position this is what we
recommend organizations to do
is to actually be very public and open
about the choices you've made
particularly those which are in a gray
area
do we use postcodes or gender as part of
our algorithm
were they perhaps you know even if
they're not illegal because they're
protected characteristics
there might be a proxy for
discrimination or
or kind of treating people unfairly and
so being public and open
is the is is the best approach we
believe because
it allows people to trust what you're
doing to understand
and also to provide feedback to you to
say look we don't agree
and that's where you match you start to
kind of
match your choices your position your
your ethical position with with where
your
public or your customers are and
a bit of a motto for us is the design ai
for the society we want to be
not the society we were in the past
because too often our machine learning
systems
are learning to replicate previous
biases
and prejudices thank you very much
i hope you enjoyed that i hope it was
[Music]
useful